il ya des gens qui ont utilisé une armée
de compte twitter pour manipuler votre
sondage d'accord alors c'est ça coûte
combien d'acheter des followers comme ça
très cher sa pensée abordable c'est
familial comme tarif on est sur du 10
euros les 1000 sur instagram et twitter
la corne c'est quelque chose d'à tarif
familial fait tarif famille
alors vous vous êtes hackers fait que ça
aujourd'hui je suis hackers
professionnels et à côté de ça je sais
écrivain j'écris des livres dont
cressard exactement donc lève-toi et
codes voilà et princesses data qui vient
d'arriver également doha dans des bois
extrêmement intéressant le bouquin vous
apprenez plein de choses et rabat des
bois donc vous toute la journée c'est
quoi votre votre métier dix heures par
jour d'écran vous fait des commandes est
exactement croyable voilà qu'on voyait
des gens qui vous disent il faut mac est
ce ce compte-là cette société set j'ai
arrêté toutes les activités qui sont
illégales mais ouais si ça tombe dans le
domaine de quelque chose que je peux
faire je décroche et on négocie c'est
quoi la demande la plus improbable qu'on
vous ait fait la chose la plus folle il
ya un peu plus d'un an et demi on m'a
demandé on a contacté pour faire chuter
un gouvernement n'ont déstabilisé très
précisément en président dans un pays
d'afrique je n'ai pas fait parce que ça
allait à l'encontre de mes convictions
et aussi parce que c'était trop
dangereux à mes yeux ça ça a été fait
par quelqu'un d'autre ou pas je ne pense
pas il ya combien de hackers en france à
peu près c'est difficile de l'estimé je
pense qu'il ya énormément de personnes
comme moi qui font de l'argent grâce à
leur ordinateur après il faut bien
distinguer les hackers éthique qui sont
dans le droit chemin comme moi et après
ceux qui font les activités criminelles
je dirais entre dix minutes 58 alors
je vous dis ce qui s'est passé c'est que
on ne peut pas se protéger de ces
attaques sur twitter parce que c'est des
comptes qui sont achetés et donc nous
sur les sondages on s'est fait piéger un
moment on n'avait plus accès à nos
sondages et on voyait que le sondage
était complètement biaisé donc c'est
quoi ils ont acheté des milliers de
followers en fait comment ça marche sur
twitter malheureusement donc vous n'avez
pas de deux paramètres qui vont vous
empêcher de falsifier ou de truquer un
sondage concrètement moi je suis
vraiment des bras je dispose d'une armée
de comptes twitter admettons 10000
compte twitter vous sûreté pmp vous
lancez un sondage je regarde le résultat
je peux très facilement inversé la
tendance du sondage en fonction de
combien de personnes a voté chez vous
bien sûr en moyenne on a fait un petit
calcul des entre 20 et 50 mille
personnes chez vous qui va tous les
soirs c'est et à côté de ça on voit sur
certains sondages qui ont été manipulés
n'explose ion du nombre de votes alors
regardez on avait fait qu'autant lanta
revient le mardi est ce qu'ils veulent
flinguer la marque regarder avant
hacking regardez regardez avant hacking
parce qu'on était à quai déjà on revient
le mardi est ce qu'ils veulent flinguer
la marque donc avant à khimki résultat
c'était ça où il ya 82 % premier après
regardez après voilà les secondes et ça
devient c'est un corps en trois secondes
ça s'est inversé il ya eu 80 % des gens
qui disent non c'est fou donc ça c'est
c'est juste vos followers en fait qui
voilà qui est dit vote et vous les
envoyer en même temps en fait voilà il
faut compte et donc ça fait ça voilà le
hacker utilise un logiciel ce qu'on
appelle un panel dans le milieu avec ce
panel en une seule commande il peut
ordonner à ses 10000 qu'on tousse et
20000 content d'aller voter non sur le
sondage de tpm paix on avait un autre
sondage comprenez vous qu'eric zemmour
ne soit pas le bienvenu à montreuil et
regardez le vrai résultat le vrai
résultat c'était non non oui à 29 mois
non mais attendez noah
comme si vous remettez avant
tout aussi alors c'était oui à 29 pour
son nom à 71% est ce qu'on n'est pas
après hacking ça a fait ça donc oui à
73% et non à 27% dont nos sondages était
fou cette semaine voit la cc c'est
incroyable on en a la preuve on est
plein de 2,2 d'exemples comme ça
donc il ya une personne qui s'est prise
qui sont épris au compte de 2 tpp
on a eu jeudi nos équipes ont reçu un
message d'un accord avec qui on s'entend
bien aussi car professionnels qu'ils on
a confirmé qu'il avait été contacté et
mandaté
par une personne par les personnes pour
changer les résultats de nos sondages
incroyable voilà et pour hacker notre
compte twitter c'est il nous envoyer
mais les captures d'écran c'est
incroyable ça quand même mais ça fait
quand même partie omniprésente de notre
vie en 2022 regarder traîne ce qui s'est
passé avec la campagne présidentielle
ont parlé d'un million de budget par
jour dépensés sur les publicités
facebook aujourd'hui on peut regarder
gagnante et du monde notamment sur les
femmes avec zemmour qui était acheta qui
a été propulsé en tendance mais qui
manquait quand même organiquement de
véritables tweet c'est quelque chose de
très fréquents en fait aujourd'hui ça
fait partie de la communication de vous
dire que c'est incroyable parce que pour
dire qu'en ce moment vraiment c'est vrai
que les gens on est on est dans l'oeil
du sud c'est vrai que voilà même nous
donc notre compte twitter sont piratés
ces incorrigibles gardez vous serrez
nouveau robin des bois est ce que vous
savez à qui profite le crime si je puis
dire est ce que vous savez qui sont les
commanditaires on a on a une petite idée
est ce que les chinois ont engagé un
hacker pense avoir qui accueille jeu je
crois savoir d'où ça vient 16h10 on peut
pas le dire là parce que c'est la
diffamation et les personnes mais on est
là c'est mon nez je venais sur un
pinceau l'enquète jeux wii
voilà et
on file plutôt politique ou profil
plutôt rivalité commerciale c'est n'ont
aucun des deux programmes et 2 arthur
non
alors non mais non mais c'est pas une
rivalité commerce images rigoler ce
qu'il a fait ça pour nuire à l'émission
pour influencer l'opinion soit son âge
sur koh lanta n'a aucun intérêt de le
hacker par exemple pour pour eux c'est
plus qu'en face à
l'influencé l'opinion opinion way we
tiendrez-vous rabbin on vous a déjà
demain droit bandé bois ce n'est pas
pardon pas son prénom
adresse vous êtes son prénom c'est
comment tu l'appelles rabbin et doit dès
lors à 20 des bois elles sont prises a
déjà demandé de hacker le twitter de tpm
paix ou de moins depuis le quai les
sondages non je suis je suis du bon côté
de la force je dirais je ne ferai jamais
ça non mon nom est venu vous demander un
on aurait pu me demander en effet mais
c'est quelque chose qui est très
fréquent c'est aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux parce que
c'est là où les gens passent du temps on
est cinq heures par jour au minimum à
avaler en fait de la data forcément
c'est le meilleur moyen de 2 pour
persuader les gens pour convaincre et
pour faire germer une idée dans la tête
percée incroyable à ce qu'on vous fait
comme révélation ce soir à 19 heures 59
en direct sur tf1 mais oui géraldine moi
je trouve que c'est absolument
incroyable ce que vous devez connaître
le documentaire derrière vos écrans de
fumée on entre évidemment de vivre ça
moi je voudrais savoir parce que
aujourd'hui cette semaine il ya eu sonia
devillers dans l'émission de karine sur
vous savez c'est ce soir c'est ce soir
oui qui a pris la parole là dessus
justement précisément dans votre
émission exactement et c'est très
étrange il a dit que les chaînages été
très exactement très dangereux à
manipuler le lendemain le lendemain
alors c'est pas sonia devillers pas dû
tourner comme l'ours en alerte mais le
lendemain en fait les sondages était
acquis
peter on utilisait comme des sondages à
l'instant t que ce n'était pas forcément
la vérité ce n'est pas les suivre et
faire celle où un référendum et je
trouve que c'est juste incroyable que
longuement sa personne le lendemain
c'est incroyable alors oui j'ai lire la
question allait peut-être un disque est
à vous poser mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup de sociétés qui sont à quai
déstabiliser et après en soit elles
reçoivent une demande de
ensemble on demande aux propriétaires de
payer mais ce que ça est ce que ça vous
est arrivé ce que ces allées jusqu'au
lac
n'a plus rien on n'a plus d'argent non
mais non mais c'est pas pareil nous
c'est des rançons c'est sur des données
médicales voilà s'échauffant données
dans les centres médicaux pour les
médecins parce qu'ils prennent quand
vous les dossiers des patients et c'est
extrêmement
handicapants nous ça rien à voir nous
lisons père l'ancien nous amène où ils
vont ils vont faire quoi nous ils vont
alors non mais nous on s'en fout demain
si ils prennent les images le ch est pas
de même mais nous on n'a pas vraiment on
s'en fout en fait c'est pas mais vous
l'avez découvert il n'y a pas d'enjeu on
l'a découvert en direct parce que c'est
le hacker qui nous l'a qui nous l'a dit
mappy 5 heures une lettre au début tu
sais pas le tournage est beau mais plus
regardée en tant que téléspectateur
juste sur twitter que je peux voir très
rapidement quand on vend seconde la
tendance inverse cela bien sûr est juste
voie de ses shows l'icm et des
téléspectateurs nous l'ont signalé nous
ont dit vos sondages sont un petit peu
bizarre en ce moment et alors vous allez
faire quoi concrètement alors ce que dit
la loi le terme piratage désigne
l'utilisation de connaissances
informatiques à des fins illégales comme
l'a dit robin des bois l'article 323 1
du code pénal sanctionne le fait
d'accéder ou de se maintenir
frauduleusement dans tout ou partie d'un
système de traitement automatisé peine
encourue deux ans de prison et 30 mille
euros damende soit s'il ya soit la
suppression soit la modification de
données contenues dans le système soit à
une altération du fonctionnement de ce
système trois ans de prison et 45000
euros d'amendé
lacker en cours également au titre des
peines complémentaires la confiscation
du matériel informatique qui a servi ou
était destinée à commettre l'infraction
donc c'est ça assez loin donc vous allez
paris quand il ya un sujet comme koh
lanta eric zemmour qui n'ont rien à voir
c'est quoi c'est pour mettre des coups
de pression pour vous envoyer un message
pour montrer qu'ils peuvent le faire oui
très rapidement et qu'ils peuvent très
rapidement entrer sur le système est
faillible pas exactement voilà oui les
gens pour le rabat des bois et est ce
que le gouvernement ou les services
secrets font appel à des hackers mais
bien sûr
c'est monnaie courante même en russie
par exemple lorsque on est un
cybercriminel qu'on se fait arrêter si
on a un bon niveau on passe pas par la
case prison on va directement au fsb qui
est l'équivalent de la dgsi ou alors ogm
rues quais l'équivalent de la dgse
française donc oui et pour ce que vous
avez dit cyril par rapport à la peine
encourue c'est ce que j'ai risqué
lorsque j'ai hacké sciences po paris
donc c'est très sérieux de sciences po
paris
vous l'avez demandé vous avez demandé de
la question se pose paris n'ont en fait
j'étais candidat pour faire sciences po
paris j'ai loupé une fois deux fois que
j'ai hacké l'école en me disant que bon
ça allait pouvoir et il avait promis de
pas porter plainte et le jour où
l'article dans le monde est sorti ils
m'ont arraché la main que j'aurais
attendu ils m'ont ils ont porté plainte
et du coup je risquais la peine que
ouais c'est vrai oui est-ce que c'est
facile d'accéder à des gros comptes de
personnalités parents de se connecter à
ses comptes vraiment les hacker pour le
coup personnalité où on a des gros
comptes comme tmp comme des comptes de
personnalités sur sur instagram mais tu
sais que tu rentres pas dans les comptes
c'est parce qu'il est maintenant mes
dires il manipule il peut manipuler les
sondages s'est très facilement parce que
il va mettre si tu fais un sondage il ya
2000 votes lui va avoir dix mille votes
en 20 secondes donc forcément ça va te
changer complètement les résultats de
son sondage mais c'est pas rentrer dans
le compte twitter c'est déjà pas mettre
des faux messages à ta place dans le
canton compte c'est ça un ravin tout à
fait ça mais il ya aussi des hackers qui
a que des gros compte de grosses
personnalités et clients sur les
revendre ou alors qu'ils font des
exactions avec bien sûr j'irai paquet
mais j'ai vu un ou deux et les mateurs
souvent parce qu'on sait que c'est
important souvent d'avoir un groupe
compte twitter le directeur des
programmes à brescia et j'ai eu parfois
le soir il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
fowler et le lendemain matin et c'est
souvent je vous entends dans la nuit que
ça se passe est ce qu'ils font appel à
vous ils vont eux mêmes ou généralement
ils font appel à moi ou alors à des
personnes comme moi et ouvre avec ça la
nuit pas forcément la nuit en fait
généralement ce qu'on essaye de faire
ces deux au lieu de faire monter tout
d'un coup on rajoute petit à petit tous
les jours de façon à ce que ça fasse
effet de croissance organique mais on
évite de tours ajoutée d'un coup sinon
c'est cramé vous comptez avec des
animateurs vous a contacté mais pas que
des animateurs des personnalités
politiques est important d'aider
influenceurs
sa dépense je peux vous faire à tarif
familial
ça va à peu près non un ordre d'idée en
fait c'est 10 euros les 1000 sur
instagram et sur twitter toman que c'est
vrai que ça se calcule en disions aux
limites à 1000 euros quoi à 1000 euros
non
dix mille îles et ses petits milles 0
les 100000
diminue
avec lui et parfaitement raison c'est
100 milles par exemple un village 10
euros lui ces 2010 1000mercis tu
m'abandonnes mais j'en veux 10 millions
pour acquis par exemple comme ça un
sondage combien la personne paye le
hacker en moyenne ainsi vous avez
intérêt ça c'est pas sûr sur le par
exemple ou me semble que dans les
sondages qui ont été trafiqués sûreté
pmp gad est celui par rapport à orpéa
là dessus je pense qu'il a dû prendre un
sérieux billets dans le sens où orpea
quand même était prêt à donner quand
exactement ils ressemblent aux
journalistes pour ne pas sortir leurs
griffes donc je pense cent mille euros
facile croyez vous que des accusations
condamné malgré tant dans les ehpad
croyez vous que ce soit des accusations
infondées regardez le sondage ça avait
été cela sans ennui à 70% non avant
voilà il y avait une soixantaine 60 mais
voilà extrêmement important en fait de
pointer du doigt cela parce que ça nous
permet de montrer que si jamais moi je
suis un téléspectateur classique je vais
sur twitter je regarde ce sondage me
dire mais entre les mariés mais béthune
et alors tu modern day avait 72 mille
votes alors que la moyenne des votes
c'est d'un mille donc c'est là aussi
qu'a commencé
le hacking